[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18
bienvenue dans ce set 8 journal du lundi
à 18 mars tout de suite les titres de
cette édition c'est le marché
international des professionnels de
l'immobilier le mipim 2019 s'est achevé
vendredi à cannes cette année encore
saint quentin en yvelines étaient sur
place
le bilan de cette participation avec
christine turc et de beauregard
directrice attractivité et immobilier
d'entreprise pour l'agglomération
la fin d'année scolaire approche et les
choix d'orientation sont à faire ce
week-end plusieurs organismes de
formation du territoire ouvraient leurs
portes à toussus-le-noble cfa des
métiers de l'aéronautique accueillait
des collégiennes le campus de
l'automobile et de la mobilité de
guyancourt lui recevait le public samedi
enfin retour sur le 12e eco trail de
paris samedi l'épreuve de 80km prenait
son départ de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines direction la tour
eiffel et pour la première fois un
athlète amputé a pris part à la
compétition
elles ne recevront également tout à
l'heure marillys macé maire adjoint de
saint germain en laye et nous ferons le
point avec elle sur la situation de la
rue au pain presque un mois après
l'évacuation d'immeubles pour risques
d'effondrement mais avant de développer
ses titres cette information and he then
un policier a mis fin à ses jours avec
son arme de service le corps de ce père
de famille de deux enfants a été
retrouvé à son domicile vendredi soir
par ses collègues
inquiète de sa non prise de service il
officie au sein de la compagnie de
sécurisation et d'intervention de limay
épisode qui témoigne sans doute du mal
être actuel des policiers des yvelines
deux semaines après le suicide d'un
agent à elancourt samedi à saint germain
en laye le raid est intervenu à chez un
autre policier retranché chez lui qui
menaçait à lui aussi à de mettre fin à
ses jours dans l'actualité aussi plus de
mille personnes réunies samedi pour le
printemps pour le futur à versailles
troisième marche pour le climat
organisée dans la cité royale
à l'initiative de plusieurs collectifs
alternatiba citoyens pour le climat
demande est des actions concrètes au
gouvernement pour la protection de la
planète l etat qui a été attaquée en
justice par des ong pour inaction
climatique
l'action de samedi a débuté par un
frozen géant devant le château de
versailles les participants se sont
ensuite rendus sur la place du marché
notre dame et devant la préfecture des
yvelines
avant d'accueillir mais les invités on
reste à versailles avec cette première
édition samedi se déroulait le salon
talents de femmes à l'hôtel de ville
organisée par une ong impliquées dans la
défense des femmes le reportage de manon
varaldo et de patrick jacques de dixmude
graphiste architectes naturopathe ou
encore avocate
au total 53 exposants étaient présentes
samedi à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour le premier salon talents de femmes
parmi elles corinne elle se lance dans
la création de couronnes de l'avent
l'idée c'est que pendant des années ma
fille née à 21 ans j'ai quatre enfants
et je leur fais des couronnes de l'avent
depuis qu'ils sont tout petits
et du coup d'année en année je me suis
rendu compte que mes copines et surtout
les enfants de mes copines on avait eu
même très envie et que du coup bah
c'était sympa d'apprendre à les faire il
était effectivement tant que je pense à
moi et que je redevienne une femme pas
qu'une mère et que du coup bas j'arrive
maintenant je vais essayer d'allier les
deux mettre en valeur ces femmes des
yvelines qui concilie vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle le
but de ce salon organisé par le club
soroptimist de versailles une ong qui
intervient pour la défense et
l'entreprenariat féminin
aujourd'hui on est très fiers de pouvoir
dire qui avec les élus des veline donc
avec notre cher maire et françois
mazières qui nous a obtenu
donner la possibilité d créé le premier
salon talents des femmes dans la région
des yvelines on met un avant tout les
talents des les femmes dans
l'entrepreneuriat dans tous les métiers
toutes les exposants du salon la même
motivation revaloriser la place de la
femme dans la sphère professionnelle
je pense que la femme est aussi un
acteur aujourd'hui important parce que
la diversité à mon sens est une vraie
synergie dans une entreprise et on a
besoin également de ce dynamisme féminin
tous les fonds récoltés à ce salon
seront reversés le 12 octobre à
l'association vivre ensemble au château
de versailles lors d'une dictée géante
avec plus de 1000 enfants d'île de
france
plusieurs jeunes enfants accueillis dans
les yvelines ils sont âgés de 5 ans et
moins et se trouvaient dans des corps du
des camps du nord-est de la syrie
le ministère des affaires étrangères
précise que ces mineurs font l'objet
d'un suivi médical et psychologique
particulier et ont été remis aux
autorités judiciaires
un accueil assuré par le conseil
départemental dans le cadre de sa
mission de protection de l'enfance et
qui donc ont été accueillis par dont ces
éminents ont été accueillis vendredi sur
le territoire des yvelines à deux
invités m'ont rejoint à présent en
plateau marillys macé bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes maire-adjointe de saint
germain en laye en charge de l'urbanisme
rester avec nous on fait le point avec
vous dans un instant sur la situation
des immeubles de la rue au pain tout de
suite on accueille christine turc et de
beauregard bonsoir enfin vous êtes
directrice de l'attractivité de
l'immobilier d'entreprise pour saint
quentin en yvelines l'agglomération qui
était présente au mipim 2010 9 à cannes
c'est le marché international des
professionnels de l'immobilier vous y
avez présenté plusieurs projets ont fait
le bilan dans un instant déjà qu'est ce
que le mipim en quelques mots quels sont
ses jeux ses objectifs et qui est
présent sur place alors le mipim surtout
le mipim 2019 était un mipim un peu
exceptionnelle puisque c'était la 30e
édition avec une thématique qui était
d'engager le futur donc vous verrez tout
à l'heure que je vous expliquerai
pourquoi saint quentin en yvelines est
également dans cette dans cette
thématique et c'est surtout le plus
grand mare
et international de l'immobilier qui
regroupe qui a regroupé cette année 26
1800 visiteurs plus de 3000 exposants 5
mais l'investisseur 100 pays représentés
et quatre jours de networking et de
conférences et on y rencontre absolument
tous les professionnels de l'immobilier
que ce soit les investisseurs les
promoteurs les conseils en immobilier
d'entreprise les architectes les bureaux
d'études et surtout des entreprises des
utilisateurs qui recherchent donc des
directeurs immobiliers qui recherchent
d'autres sites pour l'heure pour leur
implantation donc une opportunité pour
saint quentin en yvelines de faire des
rencontres
quel est l'intérêt justement pour
l'agglomération d'être sur place chaque
année alors l'intérêt surtout c'est que
nous exposons dans le cadre de grand
paris il a été grand paris qui nous
permet en fait d'avoir une visibilité de
tous les territoires franciliens avec la
même ambition c'est de valoriser le
territoire francilien est pourquoi on
expose avec avec paris région parce que
paris région et justement le premier
le premier fournisseur en fait de bureau
en bureau en europe est également
première concentration de sièges sociaux
donc c'est très important d'être d'être
sous cette bannière et nous exposons
augmenté de paris saclay dont nous
sommes le coeur économique et tout s'est
tu
tout cet ensemble est géré par paris
région entreprises c'est un événement
auquel se doit de participer 58 min
chacun a lancé plusieurs projets
présentés sur place il ya eu un focus
lui cette année particulièrement sur le
renouvellement du quartier du centre qui
est essentiellement basé sur la commune
de montigny le bretonneux si une zone de
40 mille emplois il ya également une
gare celle de saint quentin en yvelines
où transitent chaque jour 70 mille
voyageurs c'est c'est le projet phare du
moment pour l'agglomération tout à fait
en fait c'est le quartier centre c'est
le quartier prennent de saint quentin et
quand vous disiez montigny le bretonneux
c'est aussi guyancourt puisque toute
l'avenue du centre s'étale à partir du
théâtre jusqu'au crédit agricole et donc
c'est là où se font et se réalisent les
plus grosses opérations de démolition de
reconstruction et de restructuration et
grâce à cela donc nous accueillons des
entreprises qui sont en recherche de
locaux qui ont soit des locaux obsolètes
qui veulent se regrouper et du coup
grâce à ces opérations d'envergure nous
pouvons conserver les entreprises 150
ans et également faire venir d'autres
filiales lorsqu'elle se regroupent sur
le territoire c'est son soutien à un
renouveau pour ce coeur névralgique de
l'agglomération qui a quasiment pas
évolué depuis les années 70 à ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque la ville nouvelle
c'est important lui redonner un nouveau
souffle tout à fait parce que maintenant
les locaux sont complètement obsolète et
la demande des utilisateurs que ce soit
des petites ou des grosses entreprises
c'est d'être dans des locaux neufs l'ex
yb adaptable aux dernières
aux dernières
aux dernières dernière constatation
peut-être oui oui alors sur justement
sur le quartier centre de saint quentin
montigny guyancourt on a deux cent
cinquante mille mètres carrés de projets
en cours avec encore de nombreuses de
nombreuses opérations de démolition
reconstruction vers l'idée c'est de
pérenniser peut-être les entreprises qui
sont déjà présentes sur place ont attiré
aussi de nouvelles voilà tout à fait et
ce qui nous permet quand on garde des
entreprises sur le territoire
elles se regroupent avec d'autres
filiales pour exemple bmw qui a qui
construit en ce moment son nouveau siège
regroupe une filiale basée à rueil
malmaison qui frappe l alphabet de
france et donc grâce assez assez ces
projets nous pouvons capter également
des entreprises d'autres territoires non
alors qu'on dresse un bilan nous reste
deux minutes quels sont les autres
projets très rapidement que vous avez pu
présenter sur ce métier on a présenté
justement la mobilité aérienne innovante
avec le supra ce qui dans le cadre de
djo paix 2024 qui sont un formidable
catalysateur pour le pour le territoire
et dans le cadre d d d d options qui
vont se dérouler sur eux sur le
territoire on a le projet de la colline
qui est le point culminant de l'île de
france et sur lequel on veut vraiment
faire une vitrine est gardé en héritage
après les après les jeux olympiques qui
doit accueillir les épreuves de vtt pour
ces jo de 2024
si on dresse un bilan est ce que vous
avez rencontrer de potentiels
investisseurs est ce que les retours ont
été bons sur les projets que vous avez
présenté
oui alors cette année justement c'était
vraiment une forêt conjoncturel par
rapport aux par rapport aux autres
années avec un défi vraiment de
reconstruire la ville sur la ville et en
fait on était vraiment nous territoire
de saint quentin dans cette thématique
est bien évidemment on a pu on a
organisé des conférences
on a présenté tous ces projets dont on
vient de parler et grâce à ça on a de
nouveaux investisseurs qui sont en cours
d'acquisition de nouveaux immeubles sur
50 ans et notamment des investisseurs
qu'on n'avait pas encore sur le
territoire des allemands etc
donc ça c'est un point plutôt très
positif on a eu la présentation de
nouveaux projets et surtout on a eu des
demandes de nouveaux utilisateurs
d'entreprises qui sont soit dans des
locaux obsolètes soit qui veulent
s'implanter sur saint quentin et là à ce
salon qui a été très très dense on a eu
beaucoup de monde et on a on a capté des
nouveaux projets donc un bilan plutôt
positif le travail maintenant comment on
pérennise justement sur cette présence
au salon
eh ben on accompagne on continue
d'accompagner les promoteurs pour
faciliter leurs opérations et surtout
accompagner les entreprises dans leurs
projets de développement ou de
redéveloppement est donc là maintenant
on a tout un travail de fond à faire
avec
avec tous et toutes ces personnes là et
vous parliez de suppressions on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler avec le
président de 50 en huile jean michel
fourgous qui sera l'invité du 7-8
journal la semaine prochaine merci à
christine floqué de beauregard d'être
passé sur ce plateau directrice de
l'attractivité et de l'immobilier
d'entreprise pour saint quentin en
yvelines et nouvelle journée de grève
interprofessionnelle demain mardi à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats secteurs
public et privé seront dans la rue les
cheminots de versailles sont également
mobilisés ils dénoncent un plan de
suppression de 29 postes envisagées par
la direction des lignes n ai eu du
transilien à partir de mai 2010 neuf des
postes d'agent d'accueil et commerciaux
les gares notamment de villepreux
rambouillet des clayes-sous-bois ou
encore de coignières sont concernés la
cgt cheminots co organisent un
rassemblement à demain mardi devant la
gare à des chantiers à partir de 9h
avant de se diriger devant le siège est
d'ile-de-france mobilité à paris afin
d'être reçu quelques perturbations sont
donc à prévoir samedi c'était le 40e
anniversaire de la mort de jean monnet
l'un des pères fondateurs de l'europe le
président de l'ue dit jean christophe
lagarde a profité du de la journée et du
symbole pour se rendre à la maison jean
monnet située à bazoches sur guyonne
déplacement dans le cadre de la campagne
des européennes
jean christophe lagarde conduit la liste
de son parti pour le scrutin les
élections européennes se tiendront le
dimanche 26 mai prochain je me tourne à
présent vers ma deuxième invité marillys
macé bonsoir vous êtes maire adjointe en
charge de l'urbanisme à
saint-germain-en-laye alors il y a
moins d'un mois c'était le vendredi 22
février au soir 137 habitants de la rue
au pas été évacués une fragilité dans le
mur souterrain d'un bâtiment faisait
craindre un effondrement alors après
vérification plusieurs et la plupart des
habitants ont pu regagner leur domicile
sauf ceux habitant dans deux immeubles
de boutiques ont été également fermés
suite à cette découverte est ce que
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui est ce
que ces immeubles restent encore
inaccessibles
les deux immeubles restent inaccessibles
donc des locataires ont dû être relogées
des propriétaires résidant également
deux magasins en sont toujours fermés et
deux cabines et paramédicaux doivent
également retrouver un autre lieu
d'activité combien d'habitants environ
sont concernés coûté ça fait en tout
deux appartements sur un sur un immeuble
et sept autres logements sur l'autre
donc ça doit faire je dirais une
vingtaine de personnes c'est des petits
logements donc quand il n'y a pas de
grandes familles qui sont logés est ce
qu'il ya eu des solutions très vite de
relogement qui ont pu être trouvée très
rapidement parce qu'il ya une vraie
solidarité
d'abord dans la commune nouvelle saint
germain pour que des propositions ont
été faites et puis nous avons la chance
aussi d'avoir des des appartements
d'enseignants de professeur des écoles
qui était libre et on a pu aussi relogés
quelques personnes mais il va falloir
que les copropriétaires prennent en
charge dans quelque temps ce relogement
temporaire
la circulation dans la rue elle était
ouverte depuis un peu plus d'une semaine
maintenant toutes les conditions étaient
réunies pour après les premiers travaux
tout à fait on a rouvert à la
circulation
en revanche c'est vrai que devant les
immeubles qui sont en péril on a laissé
des barrières pour que les piétons ne
puisse pas y passer
on va parler dans un instant du passage
d'un expert qui est intervenu également
juste avant et ça ça a été déclenchée
dès le début des travaux de
consolidation ont eu lieu sur les deux
immeubles concernés quelle et quel était
le but justement de ces travaux tout à
fait monsieur le maire a tout de suite
diligente et une procédure auprès du
tribunal
administratif justement pour qu'un
expert judiciaire soit nommé qui a fait
son travail qui a rendu un rapport la
semaine dernière et nous sommes arrivés
avec une conclusion que cinq immeubles
ont été placés en péril grave et
imminent alors deux immeubles les deux
immeubles qui n'était déjà plus habiter
deuxième les caves de deux autres
immeubles et puis également un porche en
fond de court dans un troisième immeuble
donc voilà pour le moment nous en sommes
là des obligations et je dirais même des
injonctions ont été donnés alors la
première phase c'est c'est les études
c'est de faire un audit très approfondi
et l'expert nous a donné les pistes
c'est à dire que il faut déjà regarder
l'impact de tous les travaux de toutes
les reprises qui ont été faites depuis
la construction de ces immeubles
je rappelle qu'ils sont quand même 17e
18e 19e si on en centre ville notamment
les centres villes la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il va falloir aussi faire une
étude sur les sols savoir enfin ce qu'il
y à deux sous sous ces immeubles puis
regardez également d'où viennent les
humidité puisqu'on on hésite beaucoup à
savoir quelle est leur provenance
et puis enfin quelque chose qui peut
paraître secondaire mais qui peut être
très important c'est l'analyse des
champignons qui a été recueillie sur des
charpentes
j'imagine que ça aussi un grand intérêt
donc voilà on va déjà avoir un audit
approfondi et ensuite c'est pas terminé
on aura un second arrêté qui devra être
pris qui sera de péril nos éminents et
qui lui servira à prescrire les travaux
de soudure qui devront être absolument
fait par les copropriétaires par la
copropriété et qui seront qui seront
menés par un architecte déjà maître
d'oeuvre mais également un cabinet
d'étude et enfin un cabinet de contrôle
donc c'est maintenant dans le sérieux
c'est vraiment tout un plan d'action qui
doit être pris très rapidement à les
experts avaient à peu près moins d'une
semaine pour intervenir après le violent
ça après le rapport donc voilà c'est ans
est en cours pour les périls d'arrêtés
de péril imminent ça c'est une démarche
administrative qui déclenche le passage
de l'expert mais non je crois qu'il ne
faut pas trop trop s'y attarder même si
on comprend l'importance les c'est
surtout parce que ça permet de
déclencher des procédures et ce deuxième
arrêté si tout va bien et si la
stabilité des immeubles est retrouvé et
bien bien évidemment et on l'espère
c'est que l'on pourra réoccuper les
appartements et ça dès le début aussi
c'est la ville avait pris la décision de
débloquer en urgence un budget ça pour
aller très très vite on n'a pas attendu
que les copropriétaires se mobilisent il
fallait vraiment le faire dans le week
end
donc on n'a pas couru de risques qu'un
c'est peut-être beaucoup de précaution
mais on a préféré monsieur le maire a
vraiment préféré choisir cette solution
donc on a avancé l'argent ce qui permet
que dès le lundi matin
les thémes ans de la cave et des de
l'immeuble se fasse très rapidement en
attendant c'était vraiment pour éviter
le danger il allait dire pour agir dans
l'urgence
il y avait aussi une autre action de la
ville qui a été lancée au moment de ces
découvertes vous avez ouvert un point
d'accueil au centre administratif pour
recueillir toutes les observations des
habitants qui concerne justement les
immeubles du centre-ville est ce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup d'habitants qui sont
venus donner des observations des avis
oui il ya une vraie alors à saint
germain ya une vraie solidarité
solidarit
et pour leur logement pour nous aider à
organiser mais il ya eu la solidarité
aussi
dès qu'il y avait des informations les
gens sont venus les données donc dès le
samedi qui a suivi on avait dressé une
tente avec les élus pour pour être là
pour informer et les saint germanoise
sont venus déjà et comme il y avait
tellement de monde on a décidé monsieur
le maire a décidé de continuer le lundi
et puis les mails continuent d'arriver
donc ça nous permet effectivement on va
avoir une visibilité sur ce qui se passe
et on va pouvoir travailler avec les
copropriétaires et syndics de
copropriété parce que je rappelle la
mairie là est un peu n'est pas en
première ligne pour restaurer un
immeuble bien évidemment mais il faut
accompagner
et trouver peut-être des solutions pour
aider aussi les copropriétés les
copropriétés merci marie lise sommes
assez d'être passé sur ce plateau
maire-adjointe en charge de l'urbanisme
à saint germain en laye la sixième
édition de l'opération féminise on les
métiers de l'aéronautique s'est déroulée
vendredi dernier dans les yvelines le
cfa des métiers de l'aéronautique basée
à toussus le noble a accueilli notamment
des collégiennes l'objectif faire
découvrir la filière et casser les
préjugés
or ils iront sur ses plateaux techniques
du cfa des métiers de l'aérien à toussus
le noble
on apprend à entretenir ou encore à
réparer des aéronefs des métiers
techniques accessibles à tous
et pourtant les femmes représentent
seulement 20% des effectifs
l'idée de se faire que le mécanicien est
quelqu'un de grand costaud et c'est
aujourd'hui c'est un métier c'est un
métier qui est ouvert à tout le monde
nous avons des outillages nous avons des
moyens pour lever les les pièces etc et
non kid est un métier qui est comment
dire accessible à tous gabarits on va
dire et donc aux femmes
cette visite s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un concours national à destination des
collégiennes et lycéennes
il est porté par l'association air
emploi objectif faire évoluer les
mentalités et susciter des vocations
tels ont une visite en entreprise une
visite dans un centre de formation et
ensuite à doivent réaliser une bd sur le
thème les femmes et l'aéronautique
et elles ont un grand oral où elles
doivent restituer
leur visite comment ça s'est passé la
place de la femme
au sein de l'entreprise à
toussus-le-noble le cfa des métiers de
l'aérien accueille 240 élèves en bac pro
et bts j'ai trouvé ça intéressant après
c'est pas le métier que je voudrais
faire mais c'est sûr que c'est toujours
bien d'apprendre des choses chaque sou
jamais trouvé qu'il y avait des métiers
fait pour les hommes mais je mettrais
bien une femme faire ça aussi jours je
vois pas pourquoi il y aurait des
problèmes avec ça pour la rentrée 2010 9
le cfa des métiers de l'aérien propose
plus de 500 contrats en alternance sur
le site de toussus le noble dans les
yvelines et à bonneuil en france dans le
val d'oise des formations accessibles
dès la seconde générale et alors que la
plateforme nationale parcours sud vient
d'accueillir les derniers voeux le
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité aussi a ouvert ses portes
durant le week-end l'occasion pour les
futurs apprentis de découvrir les
formations de ce sous de ce nouveau site
pardon implantée à guyancourt
patrick jacques de dixmude et wilfrid
richy maintenance automobile réception
après vente les cursus de formation
proposés sur le campus automobile de
guyancourt sont multiples et surtout
innovant ouvert en septembre dernier
l'établissement met donc en avant ses
atouts lors des portes ouvertes
c'est un campus sur lequel vous avez une
offre de formation qui va du ca paix
jusqu'au diplôme d'ingénieur l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'était de montrer ce qu'ils
étaient les métiers de l'automobile de
montrer qu'on est sur des métiers de
haute technicité aux technologies de
pouvoir permettre au grand public de
faire des démonstrations de découvrir
les ateliers et de pouvoir leur
démontrer ce que sont les métiers de
l'eau aujourd'hui 380 stagiaires et
apprentis évolué sur le site et le
bouche à oreille fonctionne bien pour
preuve cet étudiant souhaitant se
réorienter sur les conseils d'un de ses
amis
j'ai trouvé ça très très bien parce que
l'école est propre
il ya des bonnes voitures des bons
professeurs franchement j
elle est portes ouvertes de ce week-end
s'inscrivait dans un contexte de
séduction plus large jusqu'au 23 mars
l'association nationale pour la
formation automobile organise en effet
la semaine des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité
le secteur recrute chaque année quinze
mille apprentis et 50 mille salariés
dans une centaine de métiers
les débouchés sont donc réelles d'autant
plus que les recherches pour le respect
de l'environnement se multiplient
on notera rien qu'à saint quentin en
yvelines que le secteur de l'automobile
représente au total quatorze mille
emplois et 150 entreprises le sport et
c'était 2700 runner à s'élancer samedi
pour le 80 km de l'eco-trail un départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines avec une arrivée à la tour
eiffel et parmi les participants un para
triathlètes venus porter un message
solidaire reportage de patrick jacques
de dixmude et de nicolas landry c'est
une première dans l'épreuve des 80 km de
l'eco-trail la participation d'un para
triathlète vice-champion de france 2
paratriathlon brice marmonnier s'élancer
sur cette épreuve samedi 16 mars avec un
soutien pour l'association entraide une
lame pour courir objectif sensibiliser à
l'appareillage des enfants amputés pour
faire du sport
80 km c'est plein d'incertitudes surtout
corner est déjà grande et valide
c'est une grosse distance
lord encore pu t il faut gérer les
prothèses il faut gérer le physique je
vais préparer assidûment en même temps
que ma compétence
ma saison internationale de triathlon et
aujourd'hui je suis là pour relever le
défi
brice maroni a terminé l'épreuve en
12h34 pour cette douzième édition ils
étaient deux mille sept cents
participants avec le traditionnel départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines finir les six possibles en
huit heures à 8 heures ça serait bien
comment nommer l'ex aurez-vous premier
étage vous avez une idée du temps que
vous allez mec
12h44 comme ça pas l'objectif c'est de
faire 10h10 heure et voilà en tout cas
arrivé avant demain c'est ça notre
objectif on arrive samedi
l'ambition pour nous c'est de faire
découvrir le trail et sur tout le
territoire naturel de la région
ile-de-france et la richesse du
patrimoine aussi le patrimoine
historique parce qu'il ya des lieux qui
sont vraiment absolument méconnu est
vraiment chouette à découvrir donc c'est
aussi ça qu'on veut offrir aux coureurs
pour cette douzième édition benoît
corrie est arrivé en tête au premier
étage de la tour eiffel avec un temps de
5 heures 46 minutes et pour le reste de
l'actualité sportive ne manquez pas le
cetud sport avec o comment nicolas
d'andry c'est dans un instant avant de
vous laisser elle fait partie des
édifices sauvegardés grâce au loto du
patrimoine la villa viardot à bougival
débute sa mue est les travaux de cet
hôtel particulier du 19e siècle ont
commencé un chantier qui concerne le
toit le clos du site et mais aussi le
remplacement des huisseries de la
chaufferie et de la ventilation coût
total 3,4 millions d'euros dont
notamment cinq cent mille euros financés
par le loto du patrimoine le maire de
bougival espère une réouverture en
juillet 2021 avec pour et pour les 200
ans de la naissance de pauline viardot
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal cette
édition est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]